on this Wednesday night restricted
access the border between Canada and the
US closes to all non-essential travel
we're encouraging people to stay home
who's still allowed to move Plus how
Trudeau got trumped by Trump Canada's 82
billion dollar rescue plan we have the
fiscal room to do this how the emergency
dollars are being divvied up and how to
apply for help in dire straits the first
question is like are we gonna bankrupt
the crisis for thousands of workers and
business owners and medication
recommendation what code 19 patients
should avoid
global national live Donna Friesen
reporting tonight
Robin Gill good evening and thank you
for joining us we begin with drastic new
measures to slow the spread of kovat 19
and help Canadians get through the
pandemic the canada-us border is now
being shut down to non-essential travel
as officials on both sides scramble to
fight off the virus here at home
disruptions are growing by the day and
so is the financial fallout today the
federal government unveiled a massive 82
billion dollar aid package to help
Canadians cope in these extraordinary
times our government is taking
extraordinary measures in Canada public
health should never hinge on financial
considerations
coming up we break down the numbers what
the government is promising and what's
in it to help you but first the latest
from the front lines
Quebec recorded its first death today
that brings the total number of deaths
in Canada to 9 more than 700 people have
now tested positive in Canada most of
the cases are in BC Ontario Alberta and
Quebec BC saw a major spike today 45 new
cases bringing the total to 231 Ontario
Alberta and Quebec all reported
double-digit increases elsewhere in
Canada here's where the numbers stand at
this hour we start to see a sharp rise
in cases and a number of provinces have
reported cases with no links to travel
this is a signal there is some degree of
community spreads so our time to act is
now all the provinces are ramping up
their response to the outbreak just
today
Newfoundland and Labrador and the
Northwest Territories declared public
health emergencies in BC and
Saskatchewan provincial states of
emergency are now in place a lot has
changed in this country in just one week
and officials say it won't be over
anytime soon here's Mike Armstrong with
how the government plans to help the
prime minister was beaten to the punch
just an hour before Justin Trudeau
stepped out of self-isolation
- an
it's the historic closure of the
canada-us border the US President took
to Twitter Donald Trump tweeting out
that the two countries had agreed to
shut down the border to non-essential
traffic travelers will no longer be
permitted to cross the border for
recreation and tourism now there is a
concerted effort by both governments to
ensure commercial trade continues to
flow
truckers for example are exempt when the
u.s. closed its border to China and then
later to Europe it did so unilaterally
and without warning the closure with
Canada was negotiated and mutual keeping
supply lines open is too important to
both countries there was not even an
atom a molecule of pushback on that the
other major announcement was the kovat
19 economic response plan there are two
parts there's 27 billion dollars in
direct support to Canadians and 55
billion in tax deferrals together that's
about three percent of the country's GDP
and a massive dent in the federal budget
usually my job is to ensure that we
maintain our fiscal track but right now
as Minister of Finance my only job is to
make sure that Canadians can keep food
in the fridge now the goal is to help
the people who need it most
there's an emergency care benefit for
people who don't have access to paid
leave that's about ten billion dollars
there's a program to help workers who
lose their job in this crisis five
billion dollars there's also a temporary
business wage subsidy 3.8 billion
dollars to incentivize employers to keep
workers on their payroll there's also
support for student loans and digitus
communities and homeless shelters now
autos moving the deadline for Canadians
to file their taxes instead of April
30th it's now June 1st and there's also
some relief coming for people nervous
about paying mortgages the country's six
biggest banks have agreed to allow
personal and small business customers
that have to to defer mortgage payments
for up to six months Robin Mike
Armstrong in Ottawa thanks Mike the
emergency fund is aimed at helping
Canadians pay for groceries and rent and
to help businesses meet their payroll
Abigail Beeman shows us who's eligible
and how canadians can access the aid
this Ottawa bookstore closed its doors
but is shipping out care packages they
say if they like mr. mystery books or
fiction history whatever and we have a
surprise package and we drop it but the
owner still had to put their dozen staff
on leave and have had trouble getting
through by phone to the right government
agencies for AI help others report the
service canada website is crashing as
they try to sign up anything would help
for sure two major planks of the
government plan are the emergency care
benefit and the emergency support
benefit the care benefit is short-term
help for those without paid sick leave
parents with kids out of school
caregivers for the sick and people under
quarantine
the government says people will be
eligible for up to four hundred and
fifty dollars a week for 15 weeks
starting in April you can apply through
service canada the CRA or a toll-free
number that hasn't been released yet
it will require a simple attestation
that will not require medical
documentation we want this to be as easy
as possible the emergency support
benefit is longer-term help for
Canadians who lose their jobs or hours
due to Kovan 19 but aren't eligible for
AI details are still coming about how to
apply and for 12 million low and modest
income families there's a boost to the
Canada child benefit and a one-time
goods and services tax credit Ottawa
says these two measures combined would
amount to $1,500 for a single parent
with two children
the top-ups will come to you
automatically from the CRA based on last
year's filings there's also a temporary
payroll subsidy for small employers
equal to 10% of pay up to 25,000 per
business and all of this is a start I
will highlight of course that the
emergency measures act is a significant
step not one that we feel we need today
but not one that we are closing the door
to in the future if necessary the Prime
Minister considering every option in a
rapidly evolving situation
Abigail Beeman Global News Ottawa the
u.s. is consider
a trillion dollar plan to counter the
economic fallout but it hasn't been
enough to calm investors in North
America the markets plunged again today
with trading halted briefly on Wall
Street for the second time in three days
the Dow sunk to a three-year low the
loonie was pushed below 70 cents u.s. a
five-year low and the price of crude
went crashing under $22 a barrel for the
first time since 2002 with investors
worried about a sharp drop in demand
there's a lot of volatility right now
and the US and Canada are very
interconnected
Jeff Semple is in the Niagara Falls
region where tourism is already taking a
big hit Jeff well Robyn the world's
longest undefended border is also one of
the busiest a couple hundred thousand
people crossed the canada-us border
every single day but tonight
government's on both sides are getting
ready to shut the door this is what
Niagara Falls usually looks like crowds
gathering for a glimpse of one of the
world's seven natural wonders but today
that picture postcard sits empty but
right now it's just a ghost town it's
really sad to see the owner of this
decades-old family restaurant says March
break is typically one of their busiest
weeks instead they've just laid off 80
staff this is worse than SARS she says
even 9/11 that was the last time the US
border was closed and it only lasted a
couple of days we're just hoping this
ends quickly the government says these
measures could last months but the
closure will not affect what it calls
essential travel deliveries of food fuel
and medicine two billion dollars worth
of goods crosses the border every day
supply chains including trucking will
not be affected by this new measure but
the American and Canadian governments
are shutting the door on hundreds of
thousands of others including tourists
like this family pretty empty
restaurants goals but the fall this is
what they're working
and cross-border shoppers such as this
American stocking up on Canadian candy
bars happy fish number one no Canada for
sure we need to do all we can to contain
this virus and we don't need leisure
trafficking across the border to go
shopping for cheaper gas eggs and beer
but the mayor says they will need
financial assistance from the federal
government for the many businesses and
employees affected I hope the government
comes up with something to help people
some health experts question whether
these travel bans make much of a
difference but the economic impact is
much easier to predict this is not going
to be without suffering and pain for a
lot of people particularly vulnerable
Canadians Canadians working on you know
hourly wage basis gig economy a lot of
young people who don't have you know
secure employment are on contract and
that impact felt most perhaps in these
border communities Niagara Falls does
about 80 percent of its business between
the long weekends in May and September
and they're urging Canadians to do their
part to help to curtail the outbreak and
lessen the impact on the economy as for
exactly when this border will close
robbing Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
wouldn't give a specific date except to
say very soon
Jeff sample in Queenston Ontario the
World Health Organization is clarifying
its recommendations on the use of a
popular anti-inflammatory medication the
agency says people who suspect they have
Cova 19:00 should not take ibuprofen
commonly sold as Advil or motrin instead
they should take paracetamol also known
as acetaminophen or Tylenol if they're
experiencing pain the wao says it's
still looking into the impact of
ibuprofen but there's concern it may
make kovin 19 worse those already taking
the drug for other conditions should not
stop taking the medication without
consulting a doctor
treating the rising number of Cova 19
cases will put immense pressure on our
healthcare system and that's why you've
been hearing the term flatten the curve
the goal is to do what we can to limit
transmission
selves so we don't overwhelm our
hospitals and medical workers doctors
are bracing for a surge in patients but
many hospitals were already operating at
capacity before this Eric Sorenson
reports Humber River Valley is one of
Canada's newest hospitals as ready as
any to treat the outbreak of kovat 19
but this hospital and others can only
take in what they can Italy has a
top-notch health care system - and it
was simply overwhelmed our hospital
systems in Ontario and in Canada
routinely run at a hundred percent or
higher so any surge outside of our
normal activity gets us into trouble if
we take the the worst case scenarios
kind of like what's happening in Italy
right now we could vastly overwhelm our
hospitals ability to care for everybody
especially our intensive care units one
month ago there were eight cases in this
country a week ago there were 96 look at
how the numbers have jumped upwards
since then over the last four days cases
more than doubled to 597 Tuesday night
at that pace doubling quickly there
could could be thirty thousand cases one
month from now and that is a
conservative estimate with the numbers
rising then the worry is the healthcare
systems capacity there are only so many
ICUs and ventilators if the numbers
spike beyond capacity there may not be
enough facilities and care for everyone
before the pandemic breaks with
precautions like social distancing the
curve flattens cases can rise more
slowly can be managed over time and
Canadians can count on getting the care
they need it's still relatively quiet
now but Humber River Valley expects a
surge in patients soon or not under any
any particular pressure to care for
these people but that will change very
quickly as the cases continue to rise
over the next couple weeks the experts
can see what's coming so that's why made
to act now Canadians can still make a
difference and Canada can still avert
the level of crisis they're coping with
in Italy Eric Sorenson
News Toronto so how are Canada's
hospitals preparing coming up the
mission to make room and stock up
supplies
as cases of Coppa 19 increase across
Canada health care systems are getting
ready for an influx of patients Heather
York's West looks at how hospitals
across the country are preparing for the
weeks ahead in the war against kovat 19
hospitals are the frontlines and in
cities across Canada the battle has
begun
there are patients coming into the
emergency department with by oratory
failure due to fetches concerns as
possibly over at night from the
emergency department you take care of
them to our ability and protected
ourselves for hospitals that usually
operate at or beyond capacity work is
underway to ensure there is space for
new patients Alberta Health Services is
postponing all scheduled and elective
surgeries urgent and emergency surgery
as well as oncology and scheduled
caesarian procedures will continue not
every person infected with the new
chronology as 10% could require
intensive care
Comex premier believes his provinces
health system is ready we have already
2300 beds that are waiting in case we
need to use them for the coronavirus of
course it's not just space that will be
required work is also underway to
bolster supplies and staff in Alberta
300 retired doctors are being asked to
return to work we were reaching out to
those physicians later this week to ask
them if they have an interest in coming
back into practice throughout this
pandemic but the fact is all this
preparation may not be enough if the
virus spreads too fast several provinces
have plans for things like field
hospitals if the number of six surge but
even with social distancing and
self-isolation there is a real threat
that healthcare resources could be
overwhelmed Heather Knox West Global
News Calgary still ahead the hurdles
Canadians face trying to get home
more than 200,000 people worldwide have
become infected with Coppa 19 since the
outbreak began at least 83,000 people
have recovered most of them in China
where the virus was discovered while the
number of new cases and new deaths
dropped dramatically in China it's
another story in Italy at least 475
people died in the past 24 hours the
highest death toll in a single day so
far almost 3,000 people have died in
that country Iran has also marked a
tragic milestone with more than 1,000
people dying from kovat 19 out of the
more than 17,000 cases there the
government says more than 5,300 people
have recovered the federal government is
urging Canadians abroad to come home as
borders around the world closed but for
some that's easier said than done are
your purity of crystal commencing
reports on the roadblocks when Europe
closed its borders to foreigners some
Canadians became stranded
and we feel pretty pretty desperate
Sookie Falkner and her husband were on
their way out of Barcelona on March 3rd
while boarding a train she fell and
broke her hip she had surgery but now
needs an escort nurse and says she's
been trying daily to get help from
Global Affairs Canada I'm still in some
pain I don't move well I need to be at
home my husband Canadians from all over
the world are saying they need to be
home social media is flooded with
messages the federal government is
offering loans of up to $5,000 per
person for flights and accommodations
but many are spending hours on hold or
online trying to find an airline still
flying or a hotel still taking guests
it's adding stress to the fatigue people
are already feeling this is our first
trip to Europe ever and we were supposed
to stay through till the 31st we met
Tammy and Kevin Pollard in London
they've booked a flight back to British
Columbia for Wednesday after one airline
canceled
they did make it to Heathrow with their
daughter but after security this is what
they faced closed cafes and empty
shelves definitely we're looking forward
to getting on the flight and at least
getting to Toronto and then ultimately
back to Vancouver
Stephen Roush is on the other side he's
in Alberta trying to get his mom home
from Morocco calls to the emergency
helpline touted by Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau go unanswered we feel a little a
little hopeless we feel a little lost
people are scared they want to be
reunited with their loved ones and they
want to know that they're safe given the
rapid spread of this virus and all of
the shutdowns that's just not a
guarantee right now Robin crystal
commencing in London unemployed and
uncertain up next how Canadians are
facing financial fears small businesses
across Canada are facing a harsh new
reality some are being forced to close
putting thousands of Canadians out of
work
Amanda jelly wiki has a few of their
stories it's a busy morning at Old
Montreal hotspot 11 gourmand oh but the
staff isn't preparing for an onslaught
of customers they're getting ready to
close their doors unsure if they'll ever
reopen for sure it's very scary the
first question is like are we gonna
bankrupt the company has 130 employees
like so many hospitality groups across
the country all of Angoor mondo is
facing a crisis laying off staff is the
only option we're very afraid about that
like what about like paying your
electricity your lie your rents so a lot
of questions I think people are waiting
for employees no finding new jobs is
unlikely we're gonna apply for
unemployment and we're gonna hope that
that can last us for a little bit we're
gonna be very careful
we have a bit of savings but yes it's
nerve-racking
Canada's Federation of Independent
businesses applauds Ottawa sweeping
emergency measures but the outlook
remains dire we have many members 25% of
small business in Canada think that they
won't be able to survive more than four
weeks the reality is people are scared
young parents Stephanie GABA Monta and
her husband both lost their jobs this
week GABA Monta isn't sure she qualifies
for AI because she just returned from
Matt leave she spent hours on the phone
with service canada but got no answers
my husband were talking about 55 percent
of his salary of one salary with two
children we have a mortgage to pay we're
hoping that all this hard work doesn't
just go to waste after this virus that's
attacking us a virus that didn't exist
just a few months ago is now aa pending
so many Canadian lives leaving many
asking how and when will it all end
Amanda Shelley wiki Global News Montreal
and that is global national for this
Wednesday I'm Robin Gill we leave you
tonight with some levity students are
sharing their rehearsals online with the
hashtag sunshine songs productions are
canceled so the show must go online
thank you for watching and I'll see you
back here tomorrow for the great